les acteurs du monde agricole yvelinois
ont pris la parole ce mercredi 10 avril
au château de thoiry une centaine de
personnalités de la plaine de versailles
sont venus faire un état des lieux de
leur territoire à travers des
conférences
l'objectif était de faire le bilan de ce
qui a été fait depuis dix ans et se
donner des perspectives pour les
prochaines années
l'avenir il est passionnant et il
demande beaucoup d'intelligence
collective
il est passionnant parce que les défis
environnementaux ils ne sont pas l'autre
bout de la planète il soit aussi à côté
de chez nous dans la salle des élus de
27 communes de la plaine de versailles
parmi eux des hommes politiques de saint
quentin en yvelines un territoire
composé à 20 % de terres agricoles qui
compte devenir acteurs de l'agriculture
de demain saint quentin en yvelines peut
intervenir par exemple dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement pour des nouvelles
installations pour des conversion vers
l'agriculture biologique
elle peut aussi intervenir pour
favoriser le développement de points de
vente pour les circuits courts pour une
plus grande proximité entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs
elle peut aussi intervenir en
coordination avec les communes que ça
c'est pas sa compétence directe sur
l'alimentation locale au niveau de la
restauration collective des politiques
mais également des particuliers sont
venus à thoiry c'est le cas du fondateur
de la biscuiterie les deux gourmands
installé à crépir depuis 2012 et qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de 400 points de
vente en local à terme j'ai vraiment la
sensation qu'on est en train de créer un
endroit un lieu un territoire qui sera à
terme exemplaire
j'en suis persuadé sur le mieux produire
et le mieux consommer le prochain bilan
de l'agriculture en plaine de versailles
est programmée pour l'année prochaine